COVID SITUATION.
>>D OFF THE
GLASS TO CENTE THE
GAME, A COUPLE OF ONE-ON-ONE
PUCK BATTLGOAL,
DROPPING IT OFF, ON THE
UNIT, BUT LOTS OF TALENT.
HERE'S A SHOT AND
TOOK IT OFF HIS HANDS, IN TO,
THIS GUY BLASTED ONE PASZIBANEJ
SECOND NHLTHE IND THE NET, AND
TURNOVER, TRAVIS CONNECT KNEE ,
SANHEIM TYPE TRIED TO PLAY
LOAD, KNOWN AS OF THE GAME,  FA
AT NO  THE PHILADELPHIA ZONEIS,
AND THE FINAL 30ITEMS  THIS  OFI
PANARIN, IN DIFFERENT UNIFORMS
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN
RIEMSDYK,  FOR THE TIME OT AND
WALKS IT IN AND BLASTED EARD
THEM ALL THE WAY UP THEY SCORE!
THE GAME IS THERE.
AND HE'S GOTTO.
AND THE TIP FROM GRIDER.
IN FRONT OF
AND SANHEIM, F F SOMEHOW MANAGE
REACTANTS MOTHER THAT PUCK